I could have been feeling with minimal nutrition.
So I will be able to see how at this moment you are still having all this stress.
Okay, what's the next item?
What else?
The next item is that they gave you this present.
Like all we see, prepare some presents for you.
For Taiji and me, she has this envelope.
Your grandfather also has this envelope.
So they are asking me, hey, is it okay to take this to him?
I feel that I cannot do that.
I feel that I need to see you and receive that from you.
And I hope that I am fine.
Okay, what's the next item?
The next item is something more personal.
I would like to notify you that I got the message.
Be sure that I understand what you are trying to tell you.
Be sure.
Which is what?
What if you are that you want to die, that you are a pig, that you are a person that don't necessarily be able to help you.
And should be able to donate to help some other people rather than wasting my time.
Right?
I got it.
Okay.
What else?
The other one is that I know that you insist in your, in your collaborative, your darse is getting, it's getting a lot like, like champs.
You know, from now, the moral is around Trump because he is getting that.
And that is against opening.
Who can deny that he is not an imposter?
Who can not deny that he is a billionaire?
But now all the billionaires are using this.